you are a big gamer what would you say
since you already answered the r b
question for someone else give me your
top five video games top five videos all
time of all time any console
um Grand Theft Auto like I can't pick
one specific title I just gotta say
Grand Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto as a
franchise
um the first two Apex Legends okay Apex
Legends
um I mean
as much as I hate to say it you know
Call of Duty you know you just gotta
honor you know Call of Duty you know
everybody knows Call of Duty is I can
never get into like
2K anything like that but uh man Far Cry
3.
um Smash Bros Smash Bros for sure
Smash Bros solid huh Metal Gear Solid
that was a PlayStation game PlayStation
right you never know I really know were
you like a Nintendo guy I know the
characters uh no yeah I was a Nintendo
guy yeah Sega you ever had the Dreamcast
uh no I never owned a Dreamcast but I
played it before played a couple Sonic
games or whatever yeah yeah it was
straight so no Super Mario yeah yeah I
play Super Mario play Zelda on the
switch Yeah Ocarina of Time on Nintendo
64. that's the one yeah 64 one's the one
but the Ocarina of Time was that yeah
that one was good I think that was the
gold cartridge yep yeah that [ __ ] and
then my favorite uh Mario is Mario 64.
even though I know that one likes the
one on Super Nintendo the most but I
think Mario 64 was crazy no I love that
one too that was one I got the most
memories with for sure and golden eye on
64 was [ __ ] oh yeah it's classic as
well yeah you get that gold gun yup you
[ __ ] them one-hitters spend a minute
I played it recently it wasn't as yeah
it didn't age well you know they tried
to bring it back I think like a couple
of consoles ago
and I sought it out and I played it and
I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] was not that
tight it was it was that [ __ ] and it was
uh do you remember they came out with a
game called Perfect Dark I'm in Perfect
Dark yeah and Perfect Dark was kind of
like the same type of maps as golden eye
but like in this like other world sci-fi
yeah and yeah those games did not age
the best because now you have Call of
Duty but if they did like a golden eye
like but just use the whole Call of Duty
engine it could be fire
it was like you had a Beretta an AK like
these guns on these games now these
things are [ __ ] insane yeah golden
eye feels more like a party game to me
now these days it's not really a game
everyone's hanging out everybody's
Hangouts
I got a 64 we could hook up it's not
competitive at all I'm sure there was
some competitiveness we could play what
was that one crash crash bandicoots on
Playstation what was the uh band what
was the Banjo and Kazooie yes with the
bear yeah I just played out a lot too
you ever played Glover man no but yeah
what about Earthworm Jim yes of course
okay all right so you're a gamer the
South Park game on 64.
you had to pissy snowballs right it was
so fire yeah I love that game and I'm
gonna bring that back for sure Nitro the
NWO versus WCW Wrestling oh okay yeah
that's classic yeah 64. I was more into
no mercy
yeah no 64 at some heat it's crazy
because there was like two like when I
was a kid I didn't own a 64 but my best
friend had one I had the PlayStation so
I'd like the Best of Both Worlds so when
he come to spend the night being 64 over
we get it popping I would have like
metal gear solid and
you know [ __ ] twisted metal and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] metal classic great
game